哈喽，
今天我们菲姐要教大家认识一下，
哪些财产是你的婚前个人财产？
只有我们心里对自己的财产做到心中有数，
在婚姻当中才更有底气。
首先我们要找到法律依据，
按照民法典第1063条的规定，
一方婚前的财产肯定是你的个人财产，
不会因为你结了婚，
时间一长就变成两口子共同财产了。
以前好多老一辈的人总觉得结婚超过8年，
婚前财产就变成了夫妻共同财产，
这个规定早就作废了。
现在的规定就是干脆利落，
只要是你婚前的财产，
哪怕你结婚30年、
50年，
那都还是你的个人财产。
在这里要特别注意，
婚前指的是领结婚证之前，
可不是说办酒席之前啊。
这就是为什么龙飞姐老建议大家先办酒席，
然后再去领结婚证，
为什么呢？
因为只要你办了酒席了，
那那个时候你的嫁妆啊，
礼金啊，
甚至包括彩礼钱啊都已经到手了，
这时候你还没有领结婚证，
那这些财产全都是你的婚前个人财产，
尤其是结婚办酒席收到礼金这件事儿，
现实生活当中，
钱在谁的手里基本就算是。
谁的了？
当然公平的做法是男方收男方的礼金，
女方收女方的礼金。
不过有一些家庭，
婆婆如果强势，
都被婆婆收走了啊，
丈母娘如果强势，
都被丈母娘收走了，
你要是足够强势，
那你就收着。
反过来讲，
要是你先领了结婚证再去办婚礼，
那么彩礼、
嫁妆和礼金在领完证之后才到手，
大概率下会被推定为是夫共同的财产，
但是你要是拿着证据证明其中啊，
8万是彩礼，
6万是嫁妆，
3万是礼金，
法官有可能把彩礼和嫁妆认定为是女方个人财产，
但是礼金大概率会被认定为是夫妻共同财产。
要是婚前全款买的房子，
只要在领证之前把全款交了，
合同签了就行，
不用等房产证下来了再领结证。
好多人担心全款买的房子，
房产证暂时办不下来，
所以不敢去领那个结婚证，
其实没有关系，
主要是以支付全款的时间为准，
领证之前全部付掉就可以了。
第二呢，
一方因为身体遭受损害获得的赔偿或者补偿，
这个很好理解，
比如说被车撞了得到的赔款，
上班工伤得到的赔偿款，
得了重大疾病买了。
像对应的保险，
保险公司给的理赔，
这些都属于个人财产，
你们有没有看过那种新闻啊？
就男方工伤致残得了80万的赔款，
女方离婚的时候还想分人家80万的赔款啊，
那肯定是分不了的。
说白了，
人家以牺牲身体健康换来的钱就是他个人的钱，
哪怕是婚后换来的也是他个人的财产。
第三，
以此或者赠女合同中确定只归一方的财产，
就是说爸妈去世前立下遗嘱了，
白纸黑字写的清清楚楚，
财产由你一个人单独继承，
跟你的配偶没有关系，
或者说爸妈呀，
哥哥姐姐送你一辆车，
送你一套房，
写的清清楚楚是单独赠送给你一个人的，
跟你的配偶没有关系。
在这种情况下，
才能保证父母留下来的财产归你一个人，
兄弟姊妹送的东西也归你一个人，
第四一方专用的生活用品。
什么叫专用的生活用品呢？
牙刷、
牙克和假发假牙，
衣服、
鞋子、
袜子、
裤衩子，
这肯定是属于个人的生活用品，
那手机、
电脑，
金戒指，
金项链，
金耳环，
钻石戒指，
手表、
包包这些状烂，
很多女生在分手的时候就想，
我的要订婚呢，
我。
自你去打8个金戒指，
这10个金镯子，
搞20个金耳环，
是不是这些就变成了我的生活用品，
离婚就用不着分割了吗？
你想的太简单了啊，
这些东西会不会被分割，
决定权在法官的手里，
法官会考虑哪些因素呢？
他会去衡量你们的收入水平、
资产状况，
还有你买这些金银首饰是不是在合理的范围之内，
在什么时间节点买的？
如果这头我都已经起诉离婚了，
或者都经分居了，
感情明显不合了，
然后你再用大金额的钱去买这些金镯子、
金戒指，
有可能被认定是恶意的转移夫妻共同财产，
偷鸡不成蚀把米，
到时候不光是得拿出来分，
对方还能要求多分呢？
例如其他应当归一方的财产，
这里面的内容可丰富了，
给你们总结一下，
一如果说你作为指定的受益人得到的终身寿险赔偿款，
那属于你的个人财产，
举个例子啊，
父母给自己投了一份终身寿险啊，
约定如果他们去世之后，
由你来作为受益人来享有保险公司给的理赔款，
那这笔理赔款无论是在婚前还是婚后得到，
都是你的个人财产，
那你一定要把这一笔理赔款跟你的婚后的存款要分开来要。
不放在一张卡里。
第二种情况啊，
婚前财产在婚后产生的分息，
比如说母鸡生了蛋，
母牛生了小牛，
桃树上结了桃子，
芒果树上结了芒果，
还有银行存款里的利息，
这些都叫做资息，
因为母鸡、
母牛树存款本金是你的，
所以但小牛果子利息也是你的，
但要特别注意啊，
如果你们家就是搞养殖场的，
就是搞种植的啊，
你们家养殖了那么多牛，
生下来的小牛卖钱，
这个算是经营收益了啊，
十几亩的桃树卖了桃子卖了个钱，
这个也算是经营收益了，
这个就不能单纯的说是分息了，
但是那棵树相当于本金，
还是你个人的。
第三种就是婚前的财产在婚后产生的自然增值，
什么叫做自然增值啊？
举个例子，
你婚前有一套全款的房子，
花了80万，
地段好，
旁边啊，
开通的地铁，
商场、
学校，
房子一下就涨到了380万，
多出来的300万叫做自然增值，
因为你没有为这涨了300万付出过时间精力劳动，
你只是婚前做对了这个决定，
你运气好，
随着市场环境的变化被动的涨价了。
所以这一部分还归你个人，
但如果换一个角度啊，
这房子是你婚前花80万买的，
周围的环境没有什么变化，
你老公是学设计的，
搞装修的，
在他的精心设计和装潢之下，
这房子能卖到了120万，
注意啊，
周围的房价都没涨，
就你的房子能卖这么高，
那么这个增值部分就跟你的配偶是有关系的，
因为它不单纯是自然增值的。
讲到这里，
大家有点感觉了啊，
自然增值就看你和你的配偶有没有为他付出劳动，
付出时间，
付出智慧和精力，
只要你们两口子有一个人为这件事情付出了劳动，
付出了精力，
付出了时间，
他就不叫自然增值了，
那么增值的部分就算两口子共同的财产了。
以上就是关于哪些财产原本是你的个人财产的一个总结，
希望这些内容对大家有帮助。